The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DAVID HARDT: My name is
David Hardt for those of you
who I haven't met yet.
And I'm filling in
for Duane Boning
today or sitting in or
guest lecturing, whatever
you want to call it--
AUDIENCE: You're
not guest lecturing.
You're co-lecturing.
DAVID HARDT: Oh, yeah,
I'm a co-lecturer.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's right.
No, I'm guest
lecturing because--
you know the story.
So I think my role today is
to in some ways repeat what
Duane Boning has talked about
in the first two lectures
from a little bit more of
a mechanical engineering
perspective.
But I'm going to also
throw in some things,
you might just say a personal
perspective on the problem.
And I've got too much to
try and do in one lecture,
but that's sort of
typical of me anyway.
But the notes are
on the web if you
want for the things
I have to skip over.
Now, the first
part of the lecture
is to notice this scene.
And someone was
pointing out to me
the other day, said, it must
be tough for you this summer,
because you go between
these extreme environments.
So I found this picture of
what I call a tree tunnel.
Does anybody know where
this picture was taken?
In January.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID HARDT: It wasn't at MIT?
It's a little washed out.
So you can't see what these
things are in the distance.
If you saw those you'd
probably know in an instant
if you know--
AUDIENCE: Barges?
DAVID HARDT:
Anybody in Singapore
know what that picture
might be taken?
Oh, come on.
All right, where do you
think this picture was taken?
AUDIENCE: Outside.
DAVID HARDT: All
right, OK, so here's
a tree tunnel in Acton,
Massachusetts, in January.
And here's a tree
tunnel on Sentosa island
in Singapore in January,
just about the same time,
same kind of view.
The difference is that
those are probably
the second largest collection
of container ships in the world,
something like that, which is
the main landscape feature off
of that coast of Singapore.
OK, just to let everybody
know what the other side
is enjoying on their weekends.
So here's what I want
to try to do today.
I want to go back and
talk a little bit more
about process definitions
from the point of view
of geometric change
of an object.
And I think Duane
has already talked
about this a fair amount.
But I want to relate it to that
model or that view of processes
to a couple key mechanical
processes as examples.
And then something
that we always do
is talk about this
taxonomy for control.
It's a framework.
It's all these
rather abstract terms
that say, here's a
way for you to think
about every process
that's ever been invented
and try to understand how it
relates to some other process,
with respect to
things that affect
how we control the process.
So that's our
taxonomy for control.
And then we'll go through a
couple mechanical examples.
I'll use the process of simple
machining, a turning process,
a blending process,
and a molding process.
We used to have a lab in
the course that we did--
in fact, the guys in
Singapore did it this summer
as part of their
summer orientation.
They actually did
this lab where they
went through and made parts
using these three processes.
And we studied the process
control aspect to that.
And they're
ubiquitous processes,
but they also can be reduced
to some simple enough concepts
that you can try to understand
this idea of the origins
of variation, why
did things vary,
instead of it being a
purely random event,
instead of sort of
throwing up your hands
and saying, I have no idea
why anything happened,
let's just model it
as a random process,
we say, no, let's try to
see if we can separate
those things that have a clear
cause, which we may or may not
be able to control, and those
things that we just don't know
about.
And then scrambling
at the end, I'll
try to get to this concept
of states and properties.
And again, this is more
of a framework issue.
But it is an issue of
looking at any process,
looking at all the
different factors that
enter into the
outcome of the process
and just parsing it really into
four areas in this idea of what
we'll end up calling
thermodynamics states,
those things that are kind
of transient, come and go,
and properties,
those things that
are inherent in the process.
And then we'll
separate the process
into the equipment that executes
the process, which kind stays
there day after day
and year after year,
and the material
that you're changing
as part of the process.
And, of course, that changes
in every cycle of the process.
And that distinction between
the two is extremely important.
So here's the model
you've already seen.
And the first part
of this is to notice
that we've taken the
manufacturing process and said,
well, again, there are
these two elements to it.
There's the material, which is
again sort of coming and going.
And by its very nature, the
fact that every time you
run the process,
there's a new piece
of material in
there, that's going
to have a different
characteristic
for its variability than the
equipment, which, again, is
unless you buy disposable
equipment, you generally
keep around for years.
And then there's an
interaction between the two.
And that interaction, if you
really want to abstract it,
could be called a
directed energy exchange.
It always takes some energy to
cause the material to change.
And what are you
trying to change?
You're trying to change
its geometry, usually only
its geometry.
Often properties change
as a result of that.
Or sometimes you're
changing properties,
like a hardening process or
ion implantation, something
like that.
You're taking one material
and through this process
transforming it in some way.
And, again, just
to remind you, we
have this simple functional
relationship that says,
well, guess what, the output is
a function of all the inputs.
And that's really
all it's saying.
And defining it right now,
saying that the outputs are
some vector--
or the outputs can be
described as a vector, which
has all of the relevant
geometry and property
characteristics of the process.
So it would be dimensions,
material properties,
things like that.
And process parameters,
using a really generic word
for those input
variables, because I'm
going to distinguish between
inputs and parameters
a little bit later,
and just saying
that there's some functional
relationship between the two.
And, of course, here's the
functional relationship,
all that stuff that's in there.
So if we just focus for
a moment on processes
where geometry change is
the most important one--
and I don't know, speaking from
my perspective on this class,
that's going to be 100%
of what I talk about.
I think when we get
into semiconductors,
there's a little bit more
on material modification.
But I think certainly most
of the stuff you've seen
has been on a
manufacturing process,
meaning we change the geometry.
Now, what causes the
output to change?
Well, there's a directed energy
exchange with the equipment.
And that energy
exchange can take
the form of any of the
relevant forms of energy.
So we could have a
mechanical exchange,
where you impose a force or
a displacement on something.
We can have an
electrical change, where
you run a current
through something,
or have an electric arc
something like that.
It could be thermal.
And certainly, there
are many processes
where the transfer of
heat is the key way
that you change a geometry.
And certainly, it
could be chemical.
Think of an etching process
or anything like that.
All of these energies
directed the correct way
can be thought of as
geometry change mechanisms.
Now, how do we
direct this energy?
If I just say, I've got some
thermal energy sitting around.
How do I make sure it
goes to the right place?
In effect, that's the
goal of the equipment.
That's why this one
little thing, which
my thermodynamics friends
would go crazy with,
but calling energy
a vector quantity.
It matters where you
put the energy, right?
If I want to take this
bar and maybe do something
to the center of it thermally,
and I've got a thermal energy
source out here called
a piece of equipment,
maybe a torch or
something like that,
how do I make sure it
goes to the right place?
Equipment, material.
This is one of my
easy questions.
I make sure I hold
it in place, right?
Yeah, go ahead.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So I guess by way
of relative positioning,
these two are in the
correct positions.
DAVID HARDT: Yeah, I mean if
I had like a point source,
a laser or an arc, or
something like that--
laser is a better example--
and I needed to do
something right here,
maybe thermally
deform this or join it
or something like
that, then the key
would be how both the value of
that energy and where I put it.
So location would
be really important.
So that's one way of
thinking of the concept
of a directed energy source.
If I want to bend this
piece of sheet metal, which
was originally flat, and I
have a displacement device,
it's probably a good idea for me
to put that displacement device
in the middle, not
over here, and to have
that displacement device
have a certain shape
to get what I want.
Think about this one
for a second this one.
I don't know if
you can see this.
Let me try my document camera.
Come on, doc cam.
There we go.
This is an injection
molded part.
It's from a precision yo-yo.
And what's the energy
we're talking about there?
This was injection molded.
I think most of you here have
had some hands on experience
with injection molding.
If you haven't, I'll
explain it in a few minutes.
But where's my directed
energy source there?
Or if you have any
trouble getting your head
around that, how did I
come up with that shape?
AUDIENCE: Heat and pressure.
DAVID HARDT: If I
had heat and pressure
to put the liquid
plastic in there,
that kind of filled the mold.
But what determined the shape?
AUDIENCE: The mold.
DAVID HARDT: Yeah, the mold.
And what's the directed
energy in this case?
If I'm saying the direct energy
leads to the shape of the part,
the geometry change--
AUDIENCE: The forces.
DAVID HARDT: Pardon me.
AUDIENCE: The mill
cutting courses
from whatever bit
used to cut the metal.
DAVID HARDT: We're talking
about plastic molding right now.
AUDIENCE: Right.
But to make the mold.
DAVID HARDT: Oh,
to make the mold.
Yeah, I see where
you're going with that.
But I'm thinking about
just the molding process.
The tooling somehow
was magically there.
AUDIENCE: I think the directed
energy in front of the surface.
So everywhere where we have
surface, we direct energy.
DAVID HARDT: Exactly.
So now, the one big
distinction between these two
is that here it was pretty
clear that I had a pretty
localized source of energy.
And, of course, the case of
heating this would be the same.
Or as you'll see later,
turning with a pointed tool.
Here, everything's happening
everywhere at once.
And the direction, if you
will, the spatial aspect of it
is imbued not by how
I position something,
but by the shape of the tool.
So you start to see that they're
kind of two extremes here.
There's the case where
this geometry is determined
primarily by a spatial
distribution of energy
exchange, which is
stretching it a little bit
here, but a shaped tool.
And as Simon said,
everything happens everywhere
at the same time.
Whereas in this case,
things are changing
over time and quite
different things
happening at different places.
And an more extreme case
again, which I'll get to later,
is if I'm coming in here with
some sort of a point source--
let's say heating it or
applying a force here--
there's nothing
happening out here.
It's all happening right here.
And the net shape that
I get has a lot more
to do with how I move
that interaction port,
otherwise known as a tool, than
it does with the tool shape.
Tool shape is important, but
it's of secondary importance.
OK?
They're supposed to go away now.
There we go.
OK.
Well, they didn't go away.
It's good to see you guys.
So now, we talk
about it and we say,
it's about geometry change.
And I've kind of thrown out
some different ones here.
How do you change the
shape of anything?
Well, we already
talked about one.
It's pretty obvious.
Take out a knife
and a piece of wood
and you can change its shape
by removing wood chips.
Whittling, that's your
basic shaping technique.
Well, that's essentially
one of the most common ways
of making anything.
We etch away silicon.
We machine away material.
We can oxidize and
burn things off.
We can do it in a number
of different ways.
So removal of
material is obviously
one way of doing things.
Pretty obvious one.
How else can I change
the shape of something?
AUDIENCE: You can add material.
DAVID HARDT: I can
add material to it.
Yeah.
Or join or something like that.
So I can reform things.
OK, how else?
AUDIENCE: You can
deform the material.
DAVID HARDT: I can deform
the material like this.
This started out, it's a
fixed piece of material.
I didn't add or
subtract anything to it.
But I changed the
shape by bending it.
How else?
Let me see what I've got here.
Plastic deformation
of the material.
So a constant volume,
constant mass process.
The first case, you're
throwing material away.
Adding material, which I think
is what people were already
talking about.
So one of my famous
professors here at MIT
called this machining
and negative machining.
So it's kind of another
way of thinking of it,
but adding material,
subtracting material.
The ultimate
manufacturing tool would
be one that took from
here and gave to there
and that sort of thing.
What else?
There's one other?
Where does this fit in?
It doesn't fit any of those.
AUDIENCE: Formation.
DAVID HARDT: Yeah, you
guys took 2810, right?
So you probably
already covered this.
But, yes, formation
of material, so where
you go from a liquid
or vapor state,
it solidifies against some
energy exchange medium or form
tool.
And you come up with that shape.
OK.
What else?
That's only four?
This is every
manufacturing process
in the world in the universe.
AUDIENCE: Well, it's
kind of under addition.
But you're actually
growing material,
using chemical,
biological process,
like a silicon crystal.
DAVID HARDT: OK, good.
We'll call that addition.
It ruins my punch
line if we don't.
Any others?
Well, I mean the
point is that again it
is a matter of definitions, and
you could cut this more finely.
But this pretty
nicely characterizes
every manufacturing process
with respect to geometry change.
We could have a parallel
set for property changes,
thermodynamic changes
and implantation changes,
atomic changes, so
forth and so on.
But for this it seems to
cover pretty much everything.
So if you look at a
manufacturing process
or you look at something
going on in a factory and say,
is this a manufacturing process?
One of these things
should be going on,
if it's a geometry
change process.
So what controls
the geometry change?
Was, who said, the
location and intensity
of the energy exchange.
So we already talked
about this for turning.
And here's just a schematic
of a simple turning.
This is actually the experiment
we used to do where you just--
or you guys actually did
it again, where you just
come in so-called orthogonal
turning, and you come in
and reduce the
diameter of this stock.
And more formally, we would
say this is the location
of the maximum shear stress.
You bring in a tool.
And the material is
spinning in this case.
And there's essentially
no stresses on it.
Then you come in with a
tool and start applying
a significant force over
a very limited area,
in such a way as to create
a critical shear stress,
and the material
decides to leave.
And so in an abstract sense,
I can think of machining
as locating a very concentrated
maximal shear stress
point at different
places in such a way
as to at that location make the
material disassociate with it.
Yeah, so we already talked
about this one, heat transfer
at the mold surface
and injection molding.
So another extreme of
interaction to give you an idea
that there's more
than one way to remove
material, and certainly anybody
with a mechanical engineering
education, any sort of shop
or manufacturing experience
says, oh, yeah,
machining, that's it.
And that's how you
remove material.
But, of course,
we remove material
in a lot of different ways.
And, of course, anybody from a
EE or semiconductor background
says, oh, yeah, removal,
that's chemical etching
or something like that.
And that's true also.
But then you have many things,
these beam type processes,
which are very important for
a lot of different processes.
But think the extreme
case of a process where
things are very localized and
you're just doing something
in a very small region
and then you move
that region around the part.
It might be something
like laser processing,
laser beams, using laser
beam to cut and moving it.
This is meant to be a picture
of a robot moving it around.
So the robot is very
important in this case
because it's
providing the motion
and moving the laser tool.
And, of course,
this has been taken
to extreme with these
femtosecond lasers, which
can affect at any given instant,
will only ablate material
and, I don't know
what, sub-micron areas.
So you can really localize
it if you want to.
And then you've got you've
got other things like this,
like a CVD process where
what you're actually doing
is locating a chemical reaction
across the entire surface
of something.
And again, that location
is determined primarily
by whatever substrate it
is you're trying to coat.
In this case, we're
trying to coat.
But just to throw this out,
if I have a nice clean uniform
substrate, even with--
well, let's just take a
flat one, a flat disk,
and I need to coat it with
a chemical vapor deposition
process.
So I've got this vapor, and it's
going to deposit and solidify
on the surface.
What's going to determine the
final geometry of that surface,
of that coating of the surface?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID HARDT: Yeah,
well let's assume
this is just sort of this
chamber filled with the vapor
and then you introduce
this in there.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Time.
DAVID HARDT: Time certainly
is a big part of it, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Topology.
DAVID HARDT: The topology
of the substrate.
And I'll just throw
in the other is that--
because I want to make
the point that with any
of these processes that
occur with a distribution
sort of simultaneously, the ones
that Simon was talking about
earlier, there's
always this concern
that you don't have uniform
spatial distribution.
So what I was
getting at is there
was no intention of having
directed vapor density
or anything like that.
The idea is I've got this
uniform cloud of vapor.
And it's reacting
with the surface.
So why might it vary spatially?
It's certainly going
to vary over time,
because it takes time for
this stuff to solidify.
But it's also going
to vary spatially,
because who said it's uniform?
And one of the things you
want to think about when we're
talking about manufacturing
is always sort of
question any statement of
uniformity or constancy
or things like that,
because inevitably there
will be variations because the
topography of the substrate
might change.
Who knows?
And in fact, it does
happen, especially
as you go to larger
and larger wafers.
You'll get important variations
in the chamber, temperature
variations.
You could get
concentration variations.
All these kinds of things
can cause problems.
One other that I'll
mention because I
showed this piece of
sheet metal and talked
about it as a concentrated
energy exchange.
Here's another example of
a non-concentrated energy
exchange.
This is a large
piece of sheet metal.
This dimension here is about 6
feet, aerospace manufacturing.
And it's being pulled across
this tool and deformed in here.
I actually have a sort of video
of this which I couldn't find.
But you can see it being
pulled down to the tool.
And because of the
reflections of the light,
you can see that there's
not a single portion
of this large piece of
metal that isn't being
changed at any instant in time.
So clearly, this is everything
happening everywhere
all at once.
And in effect we're pulling
it across a shaped tool.
So in the end, we're imposing
this displacement field on it.
So this gets us to this
concept of the taxonomy.
You can see that--
I've been kind of ranging
widely over a number
of different processes, either
directly or by implication.
And we want to kind of draw
some conclusions from this.
So the first is that
there are two extremes
to these interactions, the
so-called serial interaction.
And schematically here
it's best described
as my femtosecond laser,
infinitesimally small area
of interaction over
the large area.
So that at any instant
I'm only affecting
a small part of the material.
But then I move it.
I have a time history of this.
And that's what
determines the geometry.
Now, of course,
in a real process,
even with the femtosecond laser,
if you get to small enough,
there are spatially
distributed effects.
And as I go to larger
and larger tools,
this gets worse and worse.
But if we make a definition
that the area of the interaction
of the energy
interaction is small
compared to the total area
that I want to change,
then it's clearly what
we'll call a serial process.
If the opposite is true, if
the area of that interaction
is on the order
of the total area
that I'm trying to change--
and again, the icon for that
would be stamping out a car
hood or something like that--
the area of interaction
is the same as the area
that I'm trying to change.
Same with this part, the area of
interaction is the entire area.
Then we have a parallel process.
We run into a couple of
interesting variants on that.
If we take a very
common process, rolling,
to create sheet or
just plate reductions--
I'm coming in with material
that looks like this.
I'm coming out with a
material that's much thinner.
Where does this fit
in this taxonomy here,
this part of the taxonomy?
Is it a serial process
or a parallel process?
AUDIENCE: Serial.
DAVID HARDT: Serial.
OK.
OK, so we have 50%
of the electorate
going for serial in this
mostly democratic primary.
Parallel?
50% saying parallel.
I guess it goes to
the super-delegates.
OK, you guys in
Singapore and to you,
you guys, you want to
break the tie here?
What is it?
Is it serial or parallel?
AUDIENCE: I think it's parallel.
DAVID HARDT: OK, so
51% for parallel.
Anybody there say serial?
Yeah, we got some serials here.
AUDIENCE: It depends
on the light.
DAVID HARDT: Yeah.
Yeah, now, we're getting to it.
OK, it depends.
If I had drawn this
in 2D like this
and maybe sort of
drawn it in extreme
and didn't even
show this necking,
just kind of showed
it doing this,
then you'd be pretty
tempted to say,
oh, that's a serial process,
because all the action is
right here.
Look at this huge area
that I'm affecting
and all the action
is right there.
If I had drawn it in a front end
view and here's the material,
you look at that, and
say, oh, that's parallel.
Everything's happening
everywhere at the same time.
So just a cautionary
tale, it's not either
or, it's neither nor.
It's sort of preponderance
of, if you will.
So this is a good example of
why they're actually important,
even though it's mixed on here.
And I'm going to jump ahead
to the sort of who cares,
which may not have a
satisfactory answer today.
But the who cares is if
I'm running, in this case,
the Alcoa Tennessee--
that's a real town--
the Alcoa, Tennessee,
cold rolling
mill that makes all
their beer cans stock,
and I'm really concerned
about extremely good thickness
control, because when it goes
into the high speed canning
machines that thickness
has to be right on.
Otherwise, the walls will tear
or it won't form properly.
What do I control?
Just intuitively, what would I
control to affect the geometry
parameter called the thickness?
AUDIENCE: Distance.
DAVID HARDT: Distance
between the rolls, yeah.
So I control the
thickness by controlling,
let's say, this
distance right here.
Which thickness
does that control?
Does it control this
thickness right here,
or this one here, or that one
there, or maybe that one there,
or that one there?
Yeah, all you're doing--
there's one spacing area.
And if you say, oh, yeah,
it's exactly right here.
And then I make little
disks and make my cans
with the material
over here, who's
to say it's going to be right?
So even in this
case, I've actually
got a mixed problem here
and a mixed control problem.
So, yeah, here's a case
where displacement--
this trajectory we're talking
about, just like this deal,
you want to think
of it that way--
I'm directing the energy
source by displacing it.
That's part of it.
But then how do I change
the thickness distribution,
the parallel part
of the process?
Well, I'd actually
probably have to change
the shape of the rolls.
You do a little bit.
They actually do both sides.
And that does help.
But let's say I do both sides.
So this is exactly right.
This is exactly right.
And the middle looks like
this, which is not uncommon.
It becomes fatter in the middle.
What do you do?
AUDIENCE: Change the rolls.
DAVID HARDT: Yeah, but
I don't want to do that.
Yes, you would change the rolls.
And, in fact, what they
do is they build roles
with a little bit
of camber in them.
Because you know
the center is going
to deflect up a little bit.
So you put some camber into it.
Believe it or not at Alcoa,
that's still not good enough.
This stuff is very precise.
I shouldn't quote
the tolerances.
But it's on the order of in
my newly converted SI brain,
I think it could be 15 microns.
It could be in the 10,000th,
several 10,000th of inch
in terms of thickness tolerance.
It's not very thick
stuff to begin with.
AUDIENCE: It would be like
locally heated through--
DAVID HARDT: Yeah, in
fact, that's what is done.
To get small displacements,
to be able to actually
arbitrarily--
not arbitrarily-- but to
put some different profiles
on that, you'll locally heat
it or cool it in response
to the feedback to
actually slowly move
the tool locally a
little bit fatter
here and a little
bit less there.
You can imagine if you
only need 10 microns,
something like that, it
doesn't take a lot of heat.
And, yes, indeed you're
going to say, oh,
how localized can that be?
And that's the trade secret they
won't tell anybody about but.
Yeah, so in this
particular case,
notice these two different modes
of modes of interaction lead
to two different ways
of controlling it.
In one case, it's very simple.
I'm going to buy a Servo system.
It's going to be really good.
It's going to be very stiff.
And I'm going to say, make that
2/1,000 inch gap and you get
2/1,000 inch gap.
In the other case, it's
like, oh, my gosh, you know,
I've got to change this
spatial distribution somehow.
The extreme case is to
shut the thing down,
put in a new set of roles.
And the other is to come
up with some clever way
of deforming it.
So why do we worry about the
two modes of interaction?
It leads directly
to how we would ever
find the knobs on the machine
to change what we're doing.
Now, that will
become most important
in the last part of
the class when we talk
about process optimization.
And you're saying,
what can I do?
What can actually
change on a process?
What can I change real
time, millisecond?
What can I change, maybe--
in this case, this is an
unusual example-- what can I
change on a frequent basis?
But in most cases,
the major change
you do with tooling
and things like this
is on hourly shift,
yearly basis.
So your ability to
affect the output
once you've kind of
literally cast it in stone
is greatly changed
by whether it's
a parallel or serial process.
OK, so just to
summarize this again,
so for this lumped
or serial case,
the time trajectory of
that interaction port
is one of the most
important things.
So robotic manufacturing,
which was all the rage for many
a year, until we found
out it wasn't really
such a thing to
be rageful about,
it works for a limited class
of processes pretty well.
And your classic CNC
machine, the CNC machine
of the '60s, which sort of
got generalized in the '70s
and put everywhere,
essentially means
if you want to put in the
terminology of what we're
talking about today
usually means the ability
to control trajectories
in a very repeatable way.
So it's not just a machine
that can follow a trajectory,
it's also the ability to
generate the trajectory
and things like that.
And then in this distributed--
I've used two different
terms here-- but distributed
or parallel case,
more than anything,
it's the shape of the energy
distributor, you know,
patterns, molds, masks,
heat distributions,
things like that.
I think we've seen
enough examples.
We're sick of these now.
Oh, yeah, well, you'll
see this in a moment,
but a lot of the so-called
rapid prototyping
methods that popped up in
the '90s, or solid free form
fabrication as the
government likes to call it,
stereolithography, sort of
the first big one on that 3D
printing and developed
here, are serial processes.
And they figured out
how to put down--
they turn out to be usually
serial addition type
processes--
figured out how to
put a dot of material
down at a time to
build up a structure.
And that dot itself was cohesive
enough that if you put it down,
it stayed there and you didn't
need anything to hold it.
And I'll talk more about
that in just a moment.
But I think we've kind of
talked about-- these are all
interesting examples.
So if we talk about a taxonomy
to kind of bring together
the energy source, if you
will, for the geometry
change, the way we apply it,
and a couple other things that
will come up in just a
second, then we can--
and I think I've said why for
the mode, the change mode--
oh, actually I haven't.
I'm sorry about that.
Why does it matter--
let me go back to this.
I think I won't bother
with the slides.
What I called mode before
was really my energy source.
Why does it matter whether I'm
using mechanical, electrical,
thermal, or chemical
as my change agent?
What difference does that make?
It's just energy, right?
And again, back to lecture
1, what do we care about
in the process?
Quality, number
one in this class.
But also we worry about rate.
And we worry about cost.
And we worry about flexibility.
So with respect to which
energy mode is involved,
what difference does it
make in this consideration?
Simon.
AUDIENCE: Well, in the way
we can control the process,
we need to know what
[? eventually ?] is involved,
so we can change the
[? size ?] of the energy.
DAVID HARDT: Yeah,
sure, absolutely,
so I would control
these in different ways.
But let's assume
I could do that.
I know how to control
mechanical energy.
I can change forces and
displacements and velocities,
electrical currents
and voltages.
Thermal, that's a
little bit different.
I can certainly
control temperatures.
I can also try to control
their distributions.
I can sometimes control-- heat
flux is a little bit harder
to do.
And chemical, I can control
concentrations and temperatures
and maybe reaction rates
as a result of that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
if you're affecting
a large area or smaller
wafer versus a big stack of
[INAUDIBLE]
DAVID HARDT: Yeah,
I thought you were
going someplace else with that.
But, yes, there
is a size scaling.
But the example you
gave actually, though,
a wafer, in terms of the
relative size of the features
that I care about
is actually huge
when you think about
a wafer compared
to a tiny little
sub-micron line,
and then I think
about a car hood
with a little feature
in the middle,
the wafer is actually bigger.
AUDIENCE: I was thinking of the
[INAUDIBLE] with the changes
in--
I mean--
DAVID HARDT: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
OK, I think you're getting
to what I wanted to do.
Let me see if I can get any
more here and then we'll see.
Yeah, [? Kimmy. ?]
AUDIENCE: The rates
are definitely
change of [INAUDIBLE] mechanical
is usually faster than
[INAUDIBLE]
DAVID HARDT: Yeah,
yeah, believe it or not,
when you think about this, you
always think of electrical,
oh, that's the gigahertz range,
and all that kind of stuff.
And that's true if all you
need to do is move electrons.
But we have to move
material around here.
So this tends to be very fast.
If I apply a mechanical
load to something,
I can modulate that load pretty
fast these days if I want to.
And when I bring a tool
into a piece of sheet metal
like this, how long does
it take for this to react?
Well, essentially, at
the kinds of time scales
we're talking about it, it
happens instantaneously.
Compare that to how long
it takes to etch something
or do certain
deposition processes.
We're doing these nickel
plated micron scale tools.
I just saw a
presentation last night,
three days to make a tool
with 50 micron features on it.
That's not what
you'd call smoking.
So pretty low stuff.
So rate-- we can argue
different things.
You can have fast chemical
stuff and so forth and so on.
But in general, there's
a speed issue here.
What else?
That's rate.
What about quality?
AUDIENCE: There are also
side effects of the process.
DAVID HARDT: Yeah, side effects.
I like that.
Say a little bit more
about side effects.
AUDIENCE: Well, you
got the theoretical.
Maybe I want to cut
a perfect square.
But the tool is not going
cut perfectly square edges.
So depending on
what process I use,
it may have undercutting
or rounded edges.
DAVID HARDT: Absolutely.
Absolutely.
So there's something
here inherently related
to quality, at least two
things that I can think of.
One of them is related to
what I'll call diffusivity
in the general sense, not just
purely in the thermal sense.
If I apply a load to
something, as you're
saying, if I apply a load to
something, even with a point
tool, there's a stress
field that develops in it
and that sort of thing.
And this will be a
little bit facile,
but I can make an argument
that says, OK, if I apply
that load to here, it diffuses.
And so I wanted to put
the load in a tiny point,
but it actually
spread out and so
I didn't get
exactly what I want.
How about if I put a
thermal source in there?
And the worst part is not
only does it dissipate,
it just keeps dissipating.
Probably never
reaches equilibrium.
So it's really going.
How about a chemical reaction?
One of the problems we
have with that, of course,
is if you do thick etching, you
have undercutting, because it--
don't go there.
But it's going there.
It wants to go everywhere
and other things like that.
So, again, you have different
diffusion characteristics here,
depending on what's going on.
So your ability to
control the shape,
to get a minimum feature size,
to get a level of precision,
will vary depending
on what you have here.
And what else do you think
is important to quality?
Obviously, my ability
to sort of direct things
exactly where I want
them to be is important.
What else do you think
is important to quality?
AUDIENCE: How about
repeatability?
DAVID HARDT: Yeah, sort of
the how well I can repeatedly
apply this energy and have
the same thing happen.
And that will vary again,
depending on the nature
of the interfaces here.
For example, if
thermal conductivity
is a big part of it
and you're continually
bringing new material into
contact with an old tool,
it could be a different
heat transfer coefficient
every time.
In mechanical
cases, if I'm always
coming back with the same tool,
except for long term where,
maybe it's a little
bit more repeatable.
There's one other
aspect to it now.
Now, think a little
bit more about where
we're going with the
class with things
like statistical process
control, which says,
let's find out
things that are not
quite right with the
process and fix them
and that will
improve our quality.
And then in the more
active process optimization
stuff, where we say
let's adjust things
until they're really right.
And then actually
at the end, we'll
talk a little bit about
active control, where
you're continually adjusting.
But think of it this way,
because you will be thinking
about this, here's the process.
I just measured its result.
It's not good enough.
I need to improve its quality.
And I can't go
buy a new machine.
So I have to have the
ability to adjust something.
I have to have the ability
to change something.
So think about what it
takes to change these,
just as I was saying before with
the rolling case in the-- yeah,
go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I think for
some mechanical processes,
it's easier to stop.
But for the chemical, thermal,
even if you know the problem,
it can be hard to
stop the process.
It's hard to stop.
DAVID HARDT: Yeah.
I mean, I'm not trying to come
up with winners and losers
here, because they all have
advantages and disadvantages.
But you're absolutely right.
There are big differences.
If, for example, there's
a time aspect to it,
mechanically I can pull that
force off, and it goes away.
There's a wave that goes
through the material.
But it goes at sonic rates.
The thermal could take a long
time to change anything there
and certainly the chemical
depending on scale
could be like that too.
So it is important to know
what these different energy
sources are, if only to say,
OK, these types of things
are more important
when you're really
faced with the decision of
what's the best I could ever
expect this process to do.
I've worked.
I've done SBC.
I've done process optimization.
There's a fundamental
limitation because it
uses mechanical energy.
I'll never be able to do
the following or so on.
So you have these types
of things interacting
with how we apply them.
And, of course,
you could say it's
impossible to use all these
in all their different ways.
But actually that's
not entirely true.
So kind of said all that.
So let's go on.
Now, this eye
chart is an attempt
to take this entire
taxonomy and then
just populate it, this
chart, with some examples.
And some of these
are no-brainers.
And some of them could be
a little bit controversial.
So what this says
is cross here, this
is the removal mode
of transformation.
And here is addition, and
here's formation, and here's
deformation.
And in each case
then, it's divided
in half with serial and
parallel and then four different
energy sources.
So you look at each one
and say, OK, where where's
my favorite process?
So serial, removal.
Mechanical, cutting, grinding,
broaching, polishing,
water jet.
Water jet is mechanical.
It happens to be
fluid mechanical.
But it's mechanical.
Electrical, serial,
wire EDM, take
a single skinny
little wire, drill
a hole, something like that.
Put a whole bunch
of them together.
Do it all at once, say
with a formed electrode.
Now, it's parallel EDM.
Photolithography with
a wet etch if you
want to think of it that way is
basically a parallel process.
It's etching everywhere at once.
But you just happen to put
a mask in a few places.
That's your tool.
So that it can't resist.
I think Duane has already
talked about chemical mechanical
polishing, which I'm told by the
experts in the field is really
mechanical polishing.
So if we take the
C off of there,
then CMP is a mechanical
parallel process.
If it's chemical
mechanical process,
then I guess it has to
show up in both of them.
Which is it?
Is it both?
AUDIENCE: The chemistry
softens the surface, and not
the mechanical abrasion.
So you have both.
DAVID HARDT: OK.
But the chemical by itself
would not remove any material.
AUDIENCE: That's correct.
DAVID HARDT: Chemically
assisted mechanical processing.
AUDIENCE: Strangely enough,
the abrasion by itself
would no remove any material.
DAVID HARDT: Any at all?
That's interesting.
OK.
Well, that's actually
an example here
of where the chemical part is
actually affecting properties,
not unusual.
So this is still
true if I'm only
talking about the geometry
change part of it.
There's a bunch of
other ones here.
One of the interesting things
is if you come over here
to something like hot isostatic
pressing, a powder metallurgy
or powder ceramic process,
where you take uniform powders
and compress them in a mold.
So that's obviously
an addition process.
And then I sinter them and
then I do other stuff to it.
And I do it all at once
in a form tool, a can,
and I'm all set.
That's clearly a
parallel process.
And the result depends primarily
on the shape of the can.
Then Ely Sachs at MIT kind
of invented this process
called 3D printing.
And if you look at 3D printing,
it's not exactly this.
But it's essentially the
same as saying, OK, I'm
going to put down each
piece of that powder one
piece at a time.
He does it by joining the
powder one drop at a time.
He puts a binder on it.
Instead of binding
it all at once,
he puts a drop down at a time.
It's an ink jet type process.
Now, it becomes
a serial process.
And think about the difference
between these two processes.
If I've got this
big press that has
to push this powder into
a green compact, big piece
of equipment, going to
have an expensive tool,
whereas this 3D printing,
it's a desktop--
thing are desktop
versions of it--
desktop thing, all I have
to do is type in a CAD file.
It does a section file of it.
It creates this thing.
And I've got essentially
equivalent parts, not exactly
equivalent, essentially
equivalent parts.
So clearly this serial
process is much more flexible,
really great.
And I probably can
control the quality
better because of
it's not quite right,
I just change the
program a little bit.
If it was a little bit too
wide the last one I made,
I said, well, let's
reprogram the geometry
and bring it in a little bit.
And it just does it.
Whereas if I'm doing the
hot isostatic pressing,
I've got this big expensive
tool, and it's not quite right
and I can't heat it and cool
it like I did with the rolls
on the aluminum, I'm
kind of stuck with it.
So why would anybody do HIP,
when you've got 3D printing?
AUDIENCE: Rate and cost.
DAVID HARDT: Rate
and cost, absolutely.
You do the hot isostatic
pressing in minutes,
seconds, that sort of thing.
The 3D printing, the
fast ones, are going
to take you minutes to hours.
And it's volume dependent.
Whereas with the HIP,
it's much, much less so.
In general, why does anybody
do parallel processing?
Because it's really fast.
And the example I
always like to give
is imagine if someone took
a block of steel or better
yet aluminum and
said, OK, I'm going
to make all the body panels for
your car, the thin little body
panels, with my
machine tool over here.
Just imagine what it would
take to build that, as opposed
to going to a modern
high speed stamping shop.
Has anybody seen automobile
body stamping going on?
Yeah.
How long does it take to
make a side panel for a car
with like integral door frames
and all that other stuff?
Each given operation probably
takes about 2 seconds.
There's multiple stages.
So maybe we'll give it 10
seconds by the time it's done.
But blank metal in one end, and
these huge complex structures
coming out the other
end at incredible rates.
You're not going to do
that with a serial process.
Although I will say
they've done some things
with laser cutting and laser
welding where the thing really
whips along.
But it's still got a ways to go.
And it's much more costly.
So all these things do matter.
And they come in different ways.
Oh, just because I always like
to do this-- stereolithography,
how does that work?
It was the original--
I think-- the original
rapid prototyping process.
Anybody know what stereo--
what's the trade
name for that now?
That's the most
commercial of them.
There's a machine
right down the far end
of this hallway in the
architecture department
that's an STL machine.
Stereolithography?
I guess it's become passe now.
Yeah, Adam.
AUDIENCE: It's just-- I
don't know what liquid is,
but you select part of that
liquid material with the laser.
And then it runs that.
DAVID HARDT: Yeah, that's right.
There are these photo
curable polymers
that will be in a liquid
state at room temperature
and with just regular
light on them.
But if you hit them with
the right wavelength light,
they will polymerize.
They're UV curable
polymers that are
used for a lot of things,
like contact lenses and things
like that.
But this particular
case, what they said
is, well, instead of
putting it in a mold
and flashing it with
UV light everywhere,
what if we put a little
tiny spot of UV light on it?
Will it form a little
ball of polymer?
And the answer was sort of yeah.
So you have this bath.
I haven't walked by
there this month.
But there used to be one of
these glass walled classrooms
down here at the far
end of the fourth floor
in the architecture
department this white box
with a clear window in it.
And it's kind of lit up.
And there's usually
something going on in there.
And what you'll see is a bath
of nearly colorless liquid
with a platen on it.
And the platen starts at the
top with the very thin layer
of fluid on it.
And this laser,
usually not visible,
but this laser will be
dancing across the surface,
tracing an outline.
And that outline
will become solid.
And once it's polymerized, it'll
move it down and do it again.
So it's basically causing
a chemical reaction,
or in this case a polymerization
reaction, at a very small area
by hitting it with the right
amount of activation energy.
So that's stereolithography.
That would be a serial
chemical formation process.
You're going from
liquid to solid.
We also do-- in fact,
I was here last night
listening to a PhD
thesis from Singapore,
where what they did is they
took a mold, poured a UV curable
polymer on it, flashed
it with a UV lamp
over the whole thing for
about 30 seconds or something,
I think, and then
pulled it apart.
And it was all about the mold,
the mold quality, and filling
and that sort of thing.
And 90% of her thesis was
about-- well, not 90%--
a good percentage of her thesis
was about making the molds
and how well could I extract
this thing from the mold?
So physically, the same
material, the same process.
But in this case, a
really good example
of going from a
directed energy source
that was a point to a
directed energy source that
was really this entire surface.
So I guess my
point is, and now I
guess it's getting
a little bit dated,
but when these rapid prototyping
processes were all the rage,
it was interesting to notice
that on this taxonomy,
they simply, with the fact
that some people realized
and it's been done for a
lot of different things,
not just these, but
people realized that I
can take a parallel process.
And if I serialize
it, it all of a sudden
becomes a rapid
free form method.
It doesn't need any tooling.
And so you've got that example.
You've got what
turns out to be--
I guess I'd call it--
it's sort of like
a reaction molding
parallel reaction process to
a serial reaction process.
There's also with
powdered metals,
you can sinter them
thermally to get the shape.
And when people decided
they could sinter it locally
with a laser, you could
take a powder of metal
and zap it with a
laser and just get
things to sinter to
each other locally.
So they got they changed
the whole equation on how
the process is controlled,
which has effects
on all these different things.
Last thing, because
we're not going
to talk about it much
for the rest of the term,
but because it has been an
extremely important part
of manufacturing,
interestingly fading
in recent years for good
and sufficient reasons,
is flexibility.
What do you think
about if I were
to go to different
corners of this taxonomy
and say, all right, so let's put
a flexibility overlay on this?
And we'll talk about
flexibility here--
I guess, well, two common
ways of looking at flexibility
are sort of product flexibility.
So in our case, it's going to be
geometry flexibility, geometry
and material flexibility.
And the other would be
quantity flexibility,
ability to vary the capacity
or output of something
without having big
cost variances.
But let's do the first one.
We won't get into
that second one.
For flexibility of
this process to work
with different materials
in different shapes,
obviously, the extreme
example of flexibility
is every part's different.
Every part is different,
and the setup time is zero.
So mass production rates,
mass production cost savings,
but custom part capability.
These are lies somewhere
in between there.
But if I look at this
broadly, what do you think
is the most flexible?
Or most flexible
or more flexible?
If I look at the
taxonomy, what area
would you look at
for high flexibility?
AUDIENCE: Serial processes.
DAVID HARDT: Serial processes.
And why?
AUDIENCE: It's like if you're
working on a local [INAUDIBLE]
So I think it gives you more
flexibility [INAUDIBLE] I
guess feature by feature
and also part by part.
DAVID HARDT: Yeah, exactly.
I mean think of, again, the
ubiquitous example is a--
I'm trying to think of some
consumer-oriented parts
of this.
But I'm not coming up with them.
But, yeah, a machine tool.
Take a machine tool
with an end mill
and it can write your name
in a piece of plastic.
Once I programmed your name
in there and then your name
and then your name,
there's absolutely
no overhead to me switching,
because all I have to change
is the trajectory of the tool.
And nowadays with CNC control,
that's a zero cost changeover.
There's a minimal cost
in creating the programs
for simple things like that.
So, yeah, obviously, something
that is purely serial
makes a big difference.
And I'm going to add one other
thing, because if I hurry up
I'll get at least
to mention this.
I'll make the case that cutting
metal mechanically is maybe
the purest form of geometry
transformation, pure geometry
transformation with
no side effects.
So that also makes it very
flexible in that sense.
It's almost as if
all I have to do
is reprogram the trajectory
and nothing else changes
and everything's fine.
So we'll start from that.
And then we move to
other changes here.
Let's go to deformation,
serial defamation, bending.
I'm going to bend this,
three-point bending.
I'm calling it serial,
because most of the action
is happening right here.
And I'm not using form tools.
You can even think of this
as using knife-edge tools,
and I would get sort
of the same shape.
And the main thing
that determines
the shape, the main thing is how
far I push down in the middle.
So that's pretty flexible.
I mean if I want 45 degrees,
I just take it down less.
If I go down farther,
I take it down more.
But as can be shown--
and it is in the notes, but
we probably won't have time
to go through it--
as can be shown, it
makes a huge difference
what this material is and
what the underlying machine
structure looks like.
And it also-- and
this really kind of
gets us to the next
theme here-- it also
depends very strongly on the
uniformity of this material.
So I'll make the statement
that the natural variations out
of an aluminum mill, maybe not
the Alcoa, Tennessee, mill,
but the other ones,
of aluminum is enough
that it can completely
confound precise control
of a process like this.
The natural variation
of a piece of aluminum
like this that I'm
going to turn just
doesn't make any difference.
Sure, if I put a
different alloy in,
or I sneak in steel or
titanium instead of aluminum,
that's a big mess up.
But if I just say,
well, you know, here's
a piece of aluminum.
We did it in this
mill over here,
and it came out with the
following properties.
It's elasticity.
It's yield strength.
It's strain hardening
characteristics.
And then I get supposedly
the same material
from a different mill.
And they're 10% different.
Not the elasticity, by the
way, but all the others.
10% different.
Huge difference here,
virtually no difference
for the machining.
So there's an
inherent sensitivity
of the processes to that.
So if I look just at this
purely serial parallel thing,
yeah, serial is
better than parallel.
I think we can show in
general that removal
tends to be the least sensitive
to material properties.
It tends to be the least
sensitive of all these things.
So serial removal kind
of wins in most cases
in terms of flexibility.
Deformation is
generally a killer
in terms of flexibility
for these reasons
that we've talked about.
And in many cases--
well, certainly anything that
involves a parallel energy
exchange sort of starts
off behind the eight ball
with respect to flexibility.
Simon.
AUDIENCE: What about the
chemical [INAUDIBLE]??
I mean, they throw in
all sorts of parts.
And they come out
with the coating.
And I mean there
is no dependency--
DAVID HARDT: That's
a very good point.
That's a really good point.
I'm glad you raised that.
I hadn't thought about that.
But a process like this, some
of these addition processes,
any sort of a plating
or coating process
where you put stuff into
a liquid or vapor bath,
it doesn't care about
the shape, does it?
I mean at a microscopic
level it might.
But, yeah, it doesn't.
That's a good point.
So in terms of
geometry, which there's
the underlying
geometry, the substrate,
plus whatever thickness
you add, to my knowledge,
if I have a big piece over
here and right next to it
a little piece over here,
another one over here,
they're independent
of each other.
So they all deposit
at the same rate,
unless you do
something really dumb.
It's a good point.
Good point.
I don't know how
to pull that out.
But in that sense--
well, to relate it to
what we said before,
the energy exchange
area is determined
by the shape of the substrate,
not the shape of the tool.
And so in a situation like that,
the shape of the substrate,
if it's right and I can change
it each time I put it in,
I get high
flexibility with that.
Yeah, good point.
I have to remember that.
OK, enough on the taxonomy.
Now, the last thing I want to
talk about is what goes wrong.
What we've been
talking about so far--
we've made some
reference to it--
what we've been
talking about so far
is how to make major changes.
I want to go from this diameter
down to half that diameter.
Well, I have to push this in.
I have to make chips.
And I have to push
this down so far.
But what I want to talk
about is, why doesn't this
always come out to the
same angle every time?
Why is the third part
out of the run of 50
different from the 24th
part and that sort of thing?
And why, when I machine this,
is it not the same diameter
everywhere?
And so it gets into looking
at the sources of variation.
And by our definition
of a process parameter,
we're going to say,
well, it-- oops.
Don't do that.
I'll say yes, but what did I do?
By our definition of this,
it's all wrapped up somehow--
well, in the end,
it's all wrapped up
in this functional
relationship, but primarily
through these
process parameters.
So we're going to use those
to try and understand it.
So let's break down
these process parameters
in a little bit more
of a logical fashion.
And I'm going to do it
in the following way
with the following definitions.
First of all, we're
going to have alphas
associated with the equipment.
And then we're going to
have alphas associated--
let me go back here actually.
I need my picture.
So we're going to have these
parameters associated just
with the equipment.
And I think I've already
explained why we want
to distinguish between the two.
So now, we're talking about
properties, variables,
things I can adjust,
things that happen
that are staying with that
piece of iron that's bolted down
to the factory floor.
And then a similar
set, but for the stuff
that goes in and
out of the machine
or that flows
through the machine.
It doesn't go in and out.
So that's why we
distinguish between them.
So let's just focus--
I don't know, let's focus on
the machine, on the equipment.
If I think of two broad
classifications of a machine--
well, let's see,
try this exercise.
I think everybody's familiar
with a machine tool.
Simple lathe, it's sitting
here in front of us.
And it's not doing a thing.
It's not moving.
It's not even plugged in.
What alphas, what
characteristics
can you tell me about it
just by looking at it?
It's not moving.
If you were to describe it from
an engineering point of view,
what are the kinds of things
you'd worry about on it?
AUDIENCE: Stiffness.
DAVID HARDT: Stiffness.
How stiff is it?
Does it deform?
Yeah.
That's almost it.
That's a good one right there.
Stiffness, straightness,
some details
of mechanical
characteristics of it.
AUDIENCE: Thermal
expansion coefficient.
DAVID HARDT: Yeah, thermal
expansion coefficient,
very important stuff.
All those things that
basically go into
is the structure
and where I'm going
to direct that energy source
where I think it's going to be?
Now, I turn it on.
It starts moving.
And I start machining.
Forget about the chips
and all that other stuff,
but just the machine itself.
What other characteristics
of the machine
are you now going
to worry about?
AUDIENCE: The turning speed.
DAVID HARDT: Yeah, the
turning speed, exactly.
The speed.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Accuracy
of the rotation.
DAVID HARDT: The accuracy of
the rotation, yeah, OK, yeah.
But now we've got the
turning speed, now
what's the difference from
the machine's point of view
if I've got the tool
and I'm coming along--
I think you guys can see this--
if I'm coming along like this?
Right now I'm
characterizing the machine.
And now I'm characterizing
the machine.
I've hit the material, and
I'm starting the machine.
What's the difference
between when I'm here
and when I'm here?
AUDIENCE: Negative vibrations.
DAVID HARDT: Yeah,
you've skipped something.
Go ahead, I think--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID HARDT: Yeah, you
talked about the speed.
So I have a speed here, and
I have a rotation speed.
But if there's no force,
like there's no power,
there's no nothing.
No nothing much happening.
That's good grammar.
But if I come along here, all
of a sudden the force changes.
So as a minimum, you've got
these two sets of variables.
You've got how stiff
is the machine?
How does it react to
things like forces?
How straight is the machine
if I move this way relative
to the axis of rotation--
that's your accuracy thing--
is it that way?
And those are properties
that they're not
independent of whether
it's moving or not.
But you kind of
look at it and you
say it's the basic
characteristic of the machine.
And then you've got these
transient ones that are only
related to the energy exchange.
So you'd agree that
if there's no force,
there's no energy exchange.
But as soon as I have
a force and a velocity,
I'm putting mechanical
power into that thing.
And something's going to happen.
So from that we can
actually say, OK, there
are two types of variables.
Think of these sort of ones that
are intrinsic variables that
characterize the basic
properties of the machine.
And if we were doing
applied mechanics, we'd say,
those are the constitutive
properties of the material,
or they're constitutive
properties of our machine.
And then there are
the energy states,
how things change over time
as the energy waxes and wanes
and interchanges and
things like that.
And those are useful divisions,
because, for example, how
easily can I change the
stiffness of a machine?
It can be done.
I could buy a new one.
I could go in and put
in some more supports
and that kind of stuff.
Or I can take some away
and make it less stiff.
Kind of hard.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It depends
a lot on where
I have my [INAUDIBLE]
if I have a mill,
I can take the table out very
far and use it [INAUDIBLE]
DAVID HARDT: Oh,
yeah, yeah, stiffness
is not a single quantity.
You're right.
I can find stiffer regions
and less stiff regions.
But I guess what
I'm saying is if you
need to elevate the stiffness
of-- there's no acceptable spot
in it, what do you do?
You have to change the iron.
You have to go in
and make a change.
It's not something that
we would call really,
at this case, a
control variable.
On the other hand, if I need to
change the speed at which I'm
cutting, change the speed
at which I'm cutting
and it changes.
So again, there's an important
distinction between those two.
And our ability to know them
as well as to control them
is vastly different.
Now, the same thing holds true
for this, this piece of sheet
metal in its undeformed state.
This is really hard stuff.
It's like butter.
If I just put this piece
of sheet metal down here,
how would you characterize it?
Yeah, please.
AUDIENCE: Yield strength.
DAVID HARDT: Yield strength,
extremely important.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Elastic.
DAVID HARDT: Go ahead, Adam.
AUDIENCE: Elasticity.
DAVID HARDT: Yeah, elasticity.
AUDIENCE: Thickness.
DAVID HARDT: Thickness.
AUDIENCE: Temperature.
DAVID HARDT: Temperature.
Actually, I'm going to
disagree with you on that.
No.
Why does temperature matter?
AUDIENCE: Because it
changes the dimension.
DAVID HARDT: OK.
So there's a thermal expansion
characteristic on this.
That's very important point.
When I say characterizing
this, you don't characterize it
by its temperature.
You characterize it by its
reaction to temperature.
I don't characterize it
by its stress or strain.
I characterize it by its
reaction to stress or strain.
So those are all--
again, very clearly
for piece of metal,
it is constitutive properties.
And we could also worry about
its chemical reactivity and all
this other stuff.
But its inherent
characteristic of it,
which describes how it
reacts to impinging energy.
So the mechanical
energy I put in here
combined with its
elasticity, its yield stress,
and other things, determines how
far it bends and how it bends.
So we distinguish
between the two.
Again, so when this
baby is sitting here
waiting to be bent, it's got
its constitutive properties.
As it's being bent, it's
now bearing external loads
and displacements.
It's stressing and straining.
And that's a transient state.
It's an energy transfer.
And those are two
different things.
They're both important to
determining what comes out
here, because if I
said, OK, go back
to your computers
or your textbooks
and give me an analysis of what
it takes to get this shape,
you're going to need to
know the characteristics
of the material,
stiffness, yield
stress, that sort of thing.
You're also going
to need to know
what forces and
displacements I put
into it, which will tell
you what happened internally
to this thing.
What stresses and
strains did it have?
Same thing with this,
I needed to know
what the characteristic
of the polymer was.
How did it react to temperature?
What was its viscosity
with temperature?
What's its heat transfer
characteristics?
And then I needed to know
what temperature it was,
what pressure it saw, and
what the heat transfer
characteristics
of the mold were.
So what does this all lead to?
These four babies-- to two major
things, states and properties--
states and properties.
Energy states,
transient things, things
that don't hang
around, things that
are just there to accomplish
what we wanted to accomplish
and then they go away.
And properties, which, if
you will, we can change them.
But they kind of are
there when we begin,
and they're still
there when we're
done, and are more inherent to
either the equipment itself,
essentially the material
or the equipment
or inherent to the
material itself.
So when we talk
about energy states,
this one can be made
much more precise
than we have time to do here.
And those of us who are
students of system dynamics,
in the mechanical, not
in the Sturman sense,
but in the Painter
and Richardson sense
of system dynamics,
understand that you can really
do a good job of describing
the world by simply
talking about energy or power
and constitutive relationships.
And you can model anything as
how it reacts to these things.
So that's really
what we've done here.
We said the equipment
either provides or absorbs
some form of energy--
force, velocity, pressure,
flow, force displacement,
that sort of thing, voltage
current, heat transfer,
heat flow.
And those are the things
that determine specifically
what happens in the
interaction between these two.
And then the
properties, which is
sort of what's going to
happen when that energy is
transferred, are
all these things
we've talked about-- margins
of elasticity, plastic flow
properties, viscosity, sort
of almost the same thing,
resistance, inductance,
capacitance,
chemical reactivity,
heat transfer
coefficient, thermal
diffusivities,
intensive constituent
properties.
Plus, because someone
mentioned this before,
someone mentioned thickness,
so this is extremely important.
So are the other two dimensions.
These dimensions are important.
And these dimensions
are important.
And so it turns out the
object of all our affection
is actually the
geometry in the end.
So it's sort of an extensive
property of the material.
But we also have to worry about
the geometry before and after.
And we worry about
the geometry of--
obviously, the geometry of
the machine is important.
Is it straight?
Is it square that's
sort of thing.
So let me finish
up by just saying
that we can have this
model and then talk about--
and why did I bother doing this?
I mean it's kind of fun.
It's intellectually
stimulating a little bit.
But I think there's one
real benefit to it, which is
to understand why things vary.
So if I just say, all right,
I'm going to subdivide all--
by the way, all
four of these things
our subdivisions of this
vector alpha that we said
is what makes everything happen.
So I've got alpha.
And then I'm going
to divide that
into what I'll call
equipment states, equipment
properties, material states,
and material properties.
And why do I bother to do that?
Well, in the end--
I'll give you the punch line
because we're just about
out of time--
is some of these are really
easy to control, to keep fixed,
and to basically know
deterministically.
Most of them,
certain categories,
are really hard to do that with.
As an example, material
properties, yeah,
material property
of this, how well
do I know the properties
of this bar of aluminum
or this hunk of plastic?
Well, I can do some tests
and do this kind of stuff.
But, again, it can
be shown that these
can be highly
variable, particularly
as I go from this bar
to that bar to that bar.
So we're going to be able to
argue that unless you spend
a lot of time upstream
eliminating variations,
like unless you do really good
process control on the casting
and rolling and other
processes that go into,
this will have
variable properties.
So this tends to be--
material properties
tends to be variable.
And as a result, depending
on the process mechanics,
has a huge effect on
what your result can be.
Unless-- there are some
wonderful processes out there,
again, like I said, like
machining, that say,
I don't really care.
I'm very insensitive to that.
Equipment properties--
equipment property,
so the stiffness of the machine,
the temperature in a reaction
chamber, other
things like that--
I'm sorry, not temperature.
Sorry, the thermal insulation
in an oven, something like that.
Within limits, of course,
there's some uncertainty there.
It's not just variable.
I should say variable
or uncertain.
Either one is a source of
uncertainty or variation
for us.
Equipment properties, well,
again, if I pay a lot,
I'm careful with
the machine, if it
doesn't degrade a lot over
time, then I'm in good shape.
Machines degrade over time.
So tool wear is a degradation
in an equipment property.
It's an expected
dimension that's
actually changing over time.
So this can be variable
over, many cases, long times.
And that's a maintenance issue,
as much as anything else.
But again, that's within
a question of how good
the machine is.
If you build a machine
with very sloppy bearings,
a sloppy bearing is
basically a noise generator.
You just don't know
where things are.
If you build a machine that is
supposed to distribute a vapor
and it's got some sort of
a vapor handling system
that's supposed to distribute
it evenly, but it clogs easily
or something like that, or it
just wasn't designed properly,
then you've got bad properties.
It could cause variability.
Equipment states-- forces,
pressures, temperatures, flows,
velocities, what do
you think about those
in terms of our ability to
control those and eliminate
uncertainty?
Good, bad, or indifferent.
AUDIENCE: Good.
DAVID HARDT: Good.
We have a vote for good.
I would opine that any machine
built in the past 20 years,
at least, it's really good.
And that, if you will, is the
victory of CNC type controls,
of computer controls.
One of the biggest things
is that this is now
very minimal, minimal
variation or uncertainty.
I know exactly-- if I have
a good Servo and I say,
go to this velocity, it
goes to that velocity.
If I have a good
temperature regulator
and I say go to
this temperature,
it'll hold that easily
within a degree,
and in some extreme cases,
a lot less than that.
So particularly with the
use of active control,
we've made that really good.
So the last one--
and I would say end
controllable, in other words,
not only is it not
variable, I can actually
tell you what I want it to be.
So I'm going to skip discussion
of the material states,
except to say that
they're often--
well, let's say they are
variable and hard to know.
And I'll give you my one
favorite example of that.
Let's say that I
have a polymer that
needs to be at a
certain temperature
to do what it's supposed to do.
Typical way of doing that would
be put it in an oven and let it
sit in that oven.
So the oven has
certain properties
that makes it keep
uniform temperature.
And it has a really good
temperature control on it.
So if I say heat this to 100
C, it's right there at 100 C.
So I've got this
heated air, and it's
at 100 C. I take a piece of
polymer, and I put it in there.
And I wait sufficiently long
that it's at equilibrium
and the polymer is now
at 100 C. And then I
pull it out and put it
in a warming machine
or something like that.
What's the temperature of
the polymer when I formed it?
That's a state of
the polymer, right?
It's a thermodynamic
state of the polymer.
I don't know.
Unless I measure
it, I don't know.
I'm not controlling it anymore.
Now, there are also
cases, and this
is true I think in the
semiconductor world
now more than anything else
is that if I want to control
a temperature, for example, I
don't measure the temperature
of the oven or the chamber.
I measure the temperature of the
thing that I'm going to make.
And an example of that
is-- in fact, the machine
that this was made on if you
guys have used this, the ENGEL
down in Building 35, you
control the temperature
usually on this
process by controlling
the nozzle temperature and
the barrel temperature.
And you say, oh, that's the
temperature of the polymer.
But what really matters
is the temperature
of the polymer in the mold,
which you never measure.
Right?
But there's actually a little
temperature sensor in the mold
that you can measure that.
And there's also a pressure
sensor in the mold.
So you could, if you
wanted to, actually
measure the pressure on this.
But it's hard to do.
So this tends to
be-- it's knowable,
but sort of expensive to do.
So here's the
moral of the story.
Biggest source of
variation tends
to be material uncertainties,
just inherent in the material
and, if you will, the coupling
between this energy source
and how well it actually
gets into the material
through sort of an
uncertain interface.
So all of these things
here, these three,
are your sources of
variation typically
in differing measures.
This is the one saving grace.
You're going to
actually control--
way back at the
beginning of the process,
you're going to control
equipment stakes.
So when it's all said and
done, what we manipulate here
are typically, not always, but
typically equipment states.
And our ability to do
that and how well I
can change an
equipment state to get
a change, the sensitivity
of the process,
has a lot to do with what
I can do with its control.
And the rest of the lecture,
which is in the notes,
is going through
these three processes
I've talked about and kind
of addressing those issues.
So if you have a chance, take
a look at the rest of those.
OK?
OK, thank you.
Thank you all.
And I won't see you next time.
He will.